I was just very lucky to be picked out  and to have a chance and I think that's  them that's the biggest thing is like we  have to work a lot on like the way we  look but you know like we have to be  healthy all year long before the show  like a few months before the show I  start to ombre up and put up my workouts  really watching what I've been eating to  to fill my bed career-wise really opens  the doors for you for many different  jobs and you know you're all of sudden  you're walking the streets around the  world and everybody recognizes you it  takes a whole lot of confidence a good  sense of health and being able to take  care of yourself and be strong  london